Alex Jones technically was the first one
that happened here it was a test they
kic they what because of all the Sandy
Hook stuff that he was talking about and
he apologized for and he was I sorry I
was long about that one even before he
got in trouble right then then they
canceled him took his bank accounts did
all this crazy then they did Andrew
Tate same thing boom boom boom boom boom
and then there except he he got big
enough and he had so much social media
presence that like even the Ukrainian
government Ukrainian I'm sorry ukra yeah
Ro Romania kind of backed off a little
bit but they still have him under house
arrest in the country essentially but
he's not house arrested actually Tech
yeah he just roam around but he can't
leave the country and and this is and
this is like kind of the like all the
crazy that's happening is that
we're heading towards like a somewhat a
light social credit system it's sort of
like you know the the permanent record
like they that permanent record is kind
of being the switch has been flipped on
a little bit